Speaker 1: All right.
Let's take a little bit of a dove into the
deep end of the pool of hypocrisy.
I know hypocrisy doesn't matter on the American
right anymore.
I know that they will say anything and then
say the opposite if it becomes politically
convenient to make a different claim.
I know I'm very much aware of that, but this
is sort of a new low.
Some of you may be familiar with Republican
Congressman Dan Crenshaw.
Dan Crenshaw is a military veteran and while
he was in the military due to an injury, he
lost an eye and he wears an eye patch over
one eye.
Dan Crenshaw's political ideas are absolutely
terrible.
I find his views on almost every political
issue disgusting.
But we don't make fun of him for having lost
an eye.
That doesn't make any sense.
That's vile.
That's gross.
Well, this weekend I'm sorry, not this weekend.
Earlier this week.
No, it was this weekend.
Tucker Carlson referred to Congressman Dan
Crenshaw as I patch McCain, ridiculing his
physical appearance as a result of the fact
that he lost an eye through military service.
Military service.
Which Tucker Carlson, of course, has never
done.
Notably, Tucker said this while he was interviewing
former Congresswoman Tulsi Gabbard, who also
is a military veteran.
Listen to what Tucker Carlson had to say.
If you're watching, check out the sort of
non reaction from Tulsi.
Speaker 4: The more I think about it, it takes
a lot of gall for eye patch McCain to attack
moms who worry about baby formula as, quote,
pro-Russia.
I mean, that's probably one of the most outrageous
things I think I've ever heard.
Now that I'm thinking about it mean, why don't
just answer the question why?
Why the attacks?
What does that tell you?
Speaker 1: Eye patch McCain.
Eye patch McCain.
Well, it turns out that this is not just generally
a contradiction of Tucker's typical view of
we respect the military and people who have
served the country and all this different
stuff.
Tucker has actually specifically attacked
people in the past for making fun of Dan Crenshaw's
eye patch.
We have video of this.
The guys over at Midas Touch actually made
it a side by side.
And on the left of your screen, you're going
to see what Tucker had to say back in November
of 2018.
In November of 2018, comedian Pete Davidson
kind of made fun of Dan Crenshaw's eye patch,
and Tucker attacked him.
And then on the right, you will again see
what Tucker said over the weekend.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 4: Texas congressional candidate Dan
Crenshaw lost an eye to an IED in Afghanistan
on Saturday.
Actor Pete Davidson mocked him as one of the,
quote, really gross people running for office
this year.
Oh, my God.
He added, I'm sorry.
I know he lost his eye in war or whatever.
Speaker 1: Now understand that even in saying
that Pete Davidson isn't even really making
fun of the eyepatch, Pete Davidson was saying
Dan Crenshaw is a disgusting political candidate
and he's like, I know he lost an eye in war
or whatever.
Sure, the war or whatever is callous, but
he's not even really making fun of the fact
that he wears an eyepatch.
He's just saying.
Eye patch aside, I find him to be a disgusting
candidate.
And Tucker thought that that was offensive
and said it was inappropriate.
And then again, here's Tucker on.
It was indeed Monday night.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 4: So that's their position.
And they're not hiding it anymore.
Useful for you to know?
The more I think about it, it takes a lot
of gall for eye patch McCain to attack moms
who are worried about baby formula as, quote,
pro-Russia.
I mean, what.
Speaker 1: A guy, huh?
What a guy.
It's actually much worse for Tucker to do
this than Pete Davidson, to be perfectly frank,
aside from the point that Pete Davidson wasn't
even really making fun of it, he was just
a little bit dismissive of, okay, I mean,
he lost an eye in war or whatever, but he's
still a bad candidate.
Callous, but.
But not making fun of it.
It's worse for Tucker to do this because Tucker
knows Dan Crenshaw story.
He knows Dan Crenshaw's biography.
He knows exactly how Dan Crenshaw lost his
eye.
And I think at the time, at least, Pete Davidson
had a very limited understanding of Dan Crenshaw
situation.
But I know you know, this pointing out hypocrisy
no longer has an impact when we are up against
people whose view is win at all costs, attack
the other side at all costs, even for things
that we do when that's their approach, when
that's their perspective.
This type of hypocrisy doesn't actually matter.
Making fun of Dan Crenshaw's eye patch used
to be a terrible sin when Pete Davidson did
it.
But now it's fine because Crenshaw said something
Tucker Carlson didn't like.
And Tulsi Gabbard also didn't like what Dan
Crenshaw said.
And again.
I'm not defending Crenshaw as a politician.
Crenshaw's horrible.
His policy ideas are terrible.
He spreads all sorts of disinformation about
economics and what he believes socialism to
be.
We've done a ton, you know, maybe five or
six different clips debunking the things Crenshaw
has said.
But these are the people that supposedly respect
the troops, support the troops, honor military
service, eyepatch McCain.
And by the way, McCain, I can only assume
that Tucker is maybe seeing Crenshaw as in
the line of the late Senator John McCain,
which I can only imagine and infer is also
not great as far as Tucker is concerned.
I don't know.
We know that late in his life, John McCain
had some kind of departures from some elements
of the Republican Party.
It's all vile.
It's all gross.
And his viewers will never, ever, ever hold
him accountable
for it.